Marvel has been incredibly careful about
making sure that no real Avengers
endgame spoilers slip out prior to the
film's April 26th release instituting
strict controls over access to the
script and scaring the stars into
complete radio silence I've been sort of
put under surveillance by by Marvel yeah
what you talking they they got a lot of
reach in the world so it's kind of
ironic that one big spoiler might have
gotten out thanks to Marvel accidentally
including it in their own trailers yes
it's true eagle-eyed fans poring over
every frame of the recent Avengers
endgame trailer discovered that there's
apparently a discrepancy between the
normal version and the 3d version and
that difference reveals the return of
some bad guys from Avengers infinity war
it happens during the scene where Jeremy
Renner's Hawkeye runs down a tunnel to
escape a big explosion nothing spoilery
there right but reddit user andreas
Garcia 102 discovered that in the 3d
version of the trailer two figures can
be seen chasing him based on the
appearance of the figures it appears as
though the bad guys are none other than
the outriders the henchmen in Thanos his
employee who aided in the assault on
what Conda during infinity war what's
interesting here isn't just the fact
that the outriders seem to be rearing
their ugly xenomorph s heads and endgame
it's also that they aren't seen in the
2d endgame trailer only in the 3d
footage this is just pretty strongly
that Marvel may have purposely altered
the footage in the normal trailer in
order to prevent any spoilers from
leaking but apparently this detail was
missed when they were editing the 3d
version and naturally Marvel's rabid
Avengers fans discovered it right away
this is far from the first time Marvel
filmmakers namely Joe and Anthony Russo
who are responsible for infinity war and
game and Captain America Civil War have
screwed around with footage in their
trailers as a means to keep plot details
protected most famously the first
trailers for infinity war included a
sequence where the Avengers team which
had assembled to defend Wakanda included
the Hulk
however Hulk isn't anywhere to be seen
during the climactic battle because he
refused to participate forcing Bruce
Banner to fight using Iron Man's
Hulkbuster armor co-director Anthony
Russo admitted that they made up the sea
with the Hulk just for the trailer that
shot was never in the movie in that
version that you saw it was never even
created for the movie in that version it
was literally created in that version
for the trailer and his brother
co-director Joe Russo said they do that
stuff all the time we look at the
trailer as a very different experience
than the movie and I think audiences are
so predictive now that you have to be
very smart about how you craft a trailer
because an audience can watch a trailer
and basically tell you what's going to
happen in the film so at our disposal
are lots of different shots that aren't
in the movie that we can manipulate
through CG to tell a story that we want
to tell specifically for the purpose of
the trailer and not for the film that
does raise the possibility that the
presence of these outriders are also an
elaborate fake out but considering they
aren't in the normal version of the
trailer it seems more likely that they
were erased from that version rather
than added to the 3d version whatever
the case the big takeaway is that even
if this spoiler turns out to be correct
you should take everything in the
trailer with a grain of salt because any
part of it could be bogus some fans for
instance are already speculating that
the shot of Tony Stark Walking with the
team in the second trailer is a fake out
and we know that scene was heavily
edited one way or another because a
different version with different
characters appeared in the first Super
Bowl teaser there's only one way to know
the truth of course so we'll see you in
the theaters looks like the trailers did
their job after all check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about Avengers endgame or
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]